so und dann muss man am Ende dieses
Jahres auch wieder über die katholische
Kirche reden und ihren anhalten
beschämenden Umgang mit dem Thema
Missbrauch der betroffenenbeirat in dem
sich Missbrauchsopfer organisieren hat
gerade noch mal seiner Wut Luft gemacht
weil die deutschen Bischöfe auf einer
entschädigungsobergrenze von 50.000 Euro
waren für komplett ruinierte Leben nicht
zu fassen dass die noch feilschen auch
das Entschädigungsverfahren bleibt
völlig intransparent jetzt könnte man
also der Kirche an sich einen
Vollpfosten schenken oder einem Kardinal
stellvertretend Valerie hättest du deine
Idee
ja also ich finde ein Mann drängt sich
da schon auf weil er 2021 einfach
wahnsinnig viel bewegt hat also er hat
dafür gesorgt dass ich massenhaft
Gläubige zum Amt bewegt haben um dort
aus der Kirche auszutreten der Kölner
Kardinal Rainer Maria wilki er hält
monatelang einen Gutachten zum
Missbrauch in seinem Bistum zurück um
dann ein zweites Gutachten zu
präsentieren in dem vor allem sein
Vorgänger Kardinal Meißner als
Vertuscher auftauchte der hatte eine
geheime Akte mit pädophilen Priestern
unter dem Namen Brüder im Nebel als wäre
das Wetter Schuld und der Meister hat
für die Rolle des hauptschurken einen
ganz entscheidenden Vorteil er ist tot
Wölki selber will von den systemischen
vertuschereien nichts mitbekommen haben
obwohl er ja lange meistens
geheimsekretär war kann man glauben muss
man nicht ist halt eine Glaubensfrage
schadest uns allen
ist mir gesagt worden
weil du allen schadest jedenfalls denen
die noch nicht zum Austreten gekommen
sind allein der Fall des Düsseldorfer
Priesters der einst wölkis Mentor war
und den er nach dem Verdacht von
schwerstem Missbrauch eben nicht nach
Rom gemeldet hat wäre als
Rücktrittsgrund völlig ausreichend und
dann gibt das Erzbistum Köln um Wölki zu
retten auch noch einen Haufen Geld aus
das meiste Geld fast 820.000 Euro wurde
dabei für PR-Berater investiert sie
sollten in der Krise die Kommunikation
des Kölner Erzbistums verbessern tja
rund 2,8 Millionen hat das Bistum in den
letzten drei Jahren an PR-Berater
Medienanwälte und Gutachter überwiesen
an Opfer sexuellen Missbrauchs dagegen
seit 2010 insgesamt 1,5 Millionen
man muss Prioritäten setzen zur Strafe
ach nee auf eigenen Wunsch hat der Papst
Kardinal Woelki eine geistliche
auszeitverordnet Woelki geht also in
sich und trifft dort hoffentlich
jemanden an
die heute-show verleiht der katholischen
Kirche insgesamt für ihren Umgang mit
dem eigenen Verbrechen den goldenen
Vollpfosten in der Fegefeuer Edition
und dazu liebe Gemeinde singen wir Lied
306 Rainer Maria Woelki
wie das steht für war ich nicht das O
steht für oh Gott
das E steht für entschuldigung das L für
lasst mich doch
das K steht für die Kirche und für den
Kardinal für cuzifix und Kölsch Bier und
das i ist mir egal
keiner Maria Kardinal vöcki gibt alles
den Namen des Herrn
seine Maria Kardinal valkie die Pause
können wir ihm gern seine
priesterfreunde die hat der gedeckt so
wie man es in der Kirche gern tut die
Studie die hatte einfach versteckt denn
messschwein ist egal
[Musik]
alles den Namen des Herrn seine Maria
Kardinal vöcki die Pause können wir ihm
gern
und seine Kollegen
Schwader Lapp und Puff die mussten beide
gehen doch wer bleibt bis zum Schluss
genau reine Maria Kardinal Wiki wird
jetzt deine Weile geschont bei voller
Bezahlung versteht sich von selber weil
Gott seine Schäfchen belohnt
[Musik]
hallo Youtube unten könnt ihr den Kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
Infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante Videos Verlinkungen Komma
vielen Dank
[Musik]